foreign
let's go to Alexandra in San Diego
what's up Alexandra
hi Dr John Health Jay thank you guys so
much for what you do thank you so much
for calling what's up
hi so I just have a question about kind
of like the mindset issue I'm having
with combining finances so my husband
and I have actually been together for a
long time we've been together for 12
years married for seven but we never
joined our finances you know we were
young and we just thought it was smarter
to just keep it separate to avoid any
sort of issues everything was grid for a
while but you know the way I was raised
is no matter how little you make you
always save even if it's five ten twenty
dollars a paycheck and the way he was
raised is pretty much opposite they had
a lot of money they blew through it he
didn't learn how to save he just learned
how to get into debt so here we are um
you know uh 11 years into being together
we started having some issues with our
marriage where he was just drinking a
lot spending a lot of money even behind
my back lots of credit cards things like
that so then we came to a point about a
couple maybe like seven eight months ago
to where we had a separation for a
little bit we thought we were done but
we're getting divorced um but you know I
guess God brought us back together we
talked you through he decided to get
sober on his own thank God so it wasn't
me telling him like an ultimatum or
anything so now we're at a point where I
found Dave Ramsey and I've been watched
everything and I want to get to the
point where we can kind of start fresh
and kind of like almost like renew our
vows and we're gonna you know have our
finances need um combined but my biggest
struggle is I've been trying to I don't
have too much money today I only have
about 25 000 saved but it's taken me a
long time to get it um to this point and
I just feel like when I take on his debt
I feel like he committed a crime and I
am having to serve the sentence for it
and I don't know how to get out of that
mindset so that's what I'm calling you
for so number one thank you for being
honest and brave okay I'm grateful for
you okay it's been y'all been through it
okay
um
I know you are technically technically
still married you are not ready to be
fully committed to doing this thing
again yet
here's why maybe you're I'm telling you
you're not you're you want to go you
want to get back in the boat but you
want to keep one foot on Shore because
you're not fully trusting that he's all
in
or maybe you know that he's all in or it
feels like he's all in but your body is
reminding you on a daily basis hey we've
been through hell before why are you
getting back in that boat
and the scary thing about loving
somebody who struggles with any sort of
addiction
is that's the one time I might tell you
to have your own account is if somebody
is struggling with an addiction and they
are draining your money
and okay right so that's a terrifying
moment and at the same time I'm telling
you you cannot have a marriage that
works long term unless you go all in
unless you risk getting hurt again
that's the only way marriage works
that's what the word vulnerability means
I am giving you permission to hurt me
please don't
yeah
and I suffer for so long because he
could make all the mess he can why and
it never affected me financially but it
did it affected you in so many ways it
took your soul from you
true it took everything from you and by
the way if y'all are married and he dies
it's you can't be like no no no no
that's his side of the house take half
that half the couch that's just how that
works so you were living in a fantasy
you wanted the best part of being
married you love being around that guy
but you didn't want to deal with the
worst part is this guy's not trustworthy
and he's not safe
right right and so here you are you've
got a moment the deck is clear
you've got to decide am I going to go
all in and if I do go all in what are my
parameters for going all in
and that is I will not be in a situation
where I'm ever scared again and one of
the things that scares me is not knowing
how our money Works how what you're
spending stuff on where we're going to
end up financially am I going to have to
work when I'm 92 years old because my
husband drank our money away or spent
our money away right so it's it's a
matter of I won't be in a situation
where I don't feel safe anymore
and if I don't know where the money is I
don't feel safe
right yeah and I guess I'm just scared
of the future because who knows I mean
as far as the last six months have been
I've been sober and doing so
I'm bored with them with the whole
Ramsey thing that we're about to start
that together but you never know when
you know if in a year he might do
something behind my back or like start
drinking again yeah but that's all
that's all that's all marriages uh the
the great Esther perel says the worst
part about marriage is every day is a
risk every day you've been married 70
years you wake up and you're both 90 and
I wake up and say
I love you will you love me today
that's marriage my wife can do something
crazy in a year I can do something crazy
like that's life that's that's it I've
got a close buddy of mine that was
driving his family home from a family
weekend and their car rolled over a
bunch of times they got out he didn't
that's marriage that's life yeah and so
I'm also emotionally attached to my
money to where like I feel like I'm
about to you know I've been sitting for
like almost 10 years to get to like
these like lots of 25 000 I'm about to
drain it to a thousand dollars just so
you can you know I could pay off all of
his stupid decisions it's yours it's
yours
it's not his and the as long as you use
that language then stay separated
when you're ready to say this is our
money because you can't expect him to
join accounts with you but you're not
joining with him on the other side of
this thing
if you're in you gotta be him then if
you're in it's his debt and it's your
debt it's y'all's debt
okay well I think I'm gonna I think I'm
I really want to be all in
um but I guess you're right yeah I just
have to just take the risk otherwise
there's no Jade tell me if I'm wrong
here I can't think of another way of
going all in than going all in you've
got twenty five thousand dollars call
your own Bluff
foreign
not too much actually about 11 000 on
his car two thousand credit cards left
and uh about 15 in student loans
is he still actively creating debt like
is he in the face of you paying these
things off is he gonna go spend more on
a credit card
he's been really good so since he got
sober we had this whole conversation he
started doing um Uber so he goes we both
go to school we both work full time but
he also started doing you know the Uber
and Lyft at the same time so he's
working 14-hour days and he got his
credit cards down from like 15 000 down
to two and you know so he's helping he's
busting it he's helping you're just
afraid isn't the the drinking you're
afraid he's going to go back to fall
back into that
or actually surprisingly not worried
about him relaxing I'm more this is
about your money more time this is
Alexander this is about your this is
about your money
it is I'm just so attached to it because
I work so hard to earn it that I don't
want to you know just pretty much see it
all go are you is it worth your marriage
no absolutely not I gotta say I feel
like we're talking a lot about him but I
feel like now it's you Alexander it's
you I feel like now you're I hate to say
it like this but I feel like now the
problem is shifted over to maybe now
you're the problem
y'all both are the problem but you're
both the solution you you've got to
decide is this is holding your secret
holding your little pacifier blankie
that you feel like keeps you safe is
worth your Merit and if it is have the
courage to look him in the eye and say
you're not worth twenty four thousand
dollars and be done with it let him let
him go and otherwise say I'm all in I've
been asking you to be all in I'm looking
at a changed man you changed your entire
life he changed his friend Circle he
changed his his the way his body copes
with stress and rejection and fear he's
working 17 jobs to pay his debts off
why don't you join him and be all in
because he sounds like he is now
yeah no it's totally worth it I'm
definitely leaning towards that way it
just it just sucks
you can't lean you can't lean at altar
you jump you jump I go all in no one and
no one no one here is saying it's easy
here I'm like no no what you're saying
it's easy hey you can call us back at
three weeks and this could have ended
terribly that's the risk that's what
love is that's what marriage is that's
what friendship is that's what work is
it's all a risk
you just gotta ask yourself is he worth
that risk
and more importantly are you worth that
risk and I think the answer is yes I do
too I do too I think the answer is yes